hey everyone welcome to my next video
today I'm going to talk about mais
generation and specifically about
writing a mais generator with recursive
backtracking which is a great little
algorithm that can serve as a jumping
off point for generating procedural
content for gamers so what I'll go over
today is the core of the algorithm
walking through it line by line to make
sure that we all have a thorough
understanding of what's happening we'll
also look at some background going over
the depth first search algorithm for
those of you who are unfamiliar with
graph traversal and show the
similarities between the two
additionally I've written the maze
generation visualization app so we'll be
able to walk through the algorithm step
by step and watch how the overall graph
is traversed and manipulated to see how
the maze is generated so you'll be able
to see the nodes and edges and how those
are actually being generated rather than
getting caught up between generating
walls between cells lastly as always
full JavaScript source code is available
online at the github address in the
description below so you can check that
out or any of the other projects that
I've coded up so any of the other
projects I've worked on or written
tutorials about the source code should
be there anyway here it is maze
generation using recursive backtracking
first I'm gonna step back a bit and talk
about depth-first search
feel free to skip this part if you're
already familiar with it
but it never hurts to refresh and I
promise to make it really quick don't
worry so the depth-first search
algorithm is a way to traverse the graph
of nodes often associated with
traversing a tree structure so often the
examples you see especially in computer
science classes will be traversing a
binary tree or something like that the
basic algorithm is as follows starting
at a node market as visited and then for
each neighbor that's connected to this
node recursively calls this function
again what that means in plain terms is
imagine that you're walking in the woods
you're walking on a path and it diverges
into two so you can choose to go
right or left but not both if you were
using depth-first search you would
always choose to go one way let's say
that you always choose to go right and
you follow the path and it diverges
again and again you choose to go right
etc etc etc until you hit a dead end and
at that point you backtrack and you
check out the other option to check out
the road not taken' the point is is that
you follow the path as deep as it goes
with that in mind here's the pseudocode
for the depth-first search
maze generation with recursive
backtracking algorithm that's a mouthful
to say you'll immediately notice that
it's nearly identical to depth-first
search and that's not a coincidence it's
based heavily on depth-first search
so you started a node or a cell or
whatever you want to call it market has
visited and then for every neighbor that
hasn't been visited yet choose one
randomly so just roll the dice and
choose one mark that there's no wall
between these nodes anymore and recurse
on that neighbor this is nearly
identical to depth-first search with
some really minor changes of bookkeeping
but I'll show you the code and you can
see that it's just a few lines there's
really nothing to it
now that we've gone over the pseudocode
I've written a maze generation
visualization app that we can walk
through and we can see how the mazes
generated step by step so we start here
and it's just a great screen in
actuality we've got cells so we've got
eight across and four down and each one
of them has walls all around them so
they're starting with they're starting
with no paths between anywhere now a lot
of examples like to work in terms of
removing walls but what you're actually
doing when you're generating a maze is
that you're generating the edges between
cells so I'm gonna remove the walls
again
and I'm going to show you those are the
nodes for every cell and those are all
the potential edges now I didn't say
they're actual edges those are only the
potential neighbors for each cell and as
we walk through this we'll fill in the
edges and you'll see how those relate to
the walls so I'm gonna step so the blue
indicates that this is the visited node
right now this is the currently active
node okay the red circle means that this
node has been visited and the green
lines mean that these are the edges to
neighbors that haven't been visited yet
so as we step you remember if you
remember back to the pseudocode what we
do is we randomly choose one of the
neighbors that hasn't been visited yet
so let's just step it you can see that
the previous cell that we were in the
node went red and what what that means
is is that it's been visited and now we
can't go back there again and the edge
between them is also red
at the new position we've got three
cells that connect here the one above
which is read the one below and the one
to the right and both of those have
green edges to them so that means that
we can actually connect that means we
can actually visit them so let's advance
again now I've colored the edge between
the two red nodes blue and that's just
to indicate that there exists an edge
now between them at the current active
cell the one with the blue square the
cell above it has a red node and the
cell to the right and down both have
green nodes so we can only go to the
right or down again let's hope it goes
somewhere good this time
all right it went to the right which is
nice at the new position you've got four
options you can go left right up and
down except that the node to the left
has already been visited so that way is
blocked you can only go up down or to
the right now I'm going to hide the
nodes again and I'm going to show the
walls and you can see that the walls
follow where the edges are so wherever
there's no edge between a node there's a
wall and let's step this a few more
times now so we can a step in a step and
this is interesting now it has nowhere
to go
it's advanced to the bottom left corner
and there are no nodes around it that
haven't been visited yet if you remember
back to the pseudocode once you reach
this situation and there are no more
neighbors that haven't been visited yet
what you're going to do is you're gonna
backtrack so as we advance again it goes
back and you can see that there's a
possibility now to go to the right but
not up because we've already visited the
node above it so stepping again you can
see that there are nodes to the right
and up but it can't go to the left and
let's take a look at the walls while
we're here and it's starting to look
like a maze it will take us a few more
steps here up here you can move to the
right or up
let's see which way it goes okay went up
again and this way you can go up left or
right at this point there's only up
because left down and right have all
been visited already so it's going to
take it's going to move up move to the
right move to the right and now it has
options again and you can see that all
that's doing is choosing between the
notes where it has a possible path if
not allowed to visit a node that is
already visited yet it's not allowed to
visit a node that it's already visited
so the only path that can take is right
or down again up right or down and went
right will go which way will it go now
right down if it goes to the left it's
gonna be forced to go to the end of the
path and then it'll have to backtrack so
let's see if it goes dad aren't so it's
gonna go right yay up
I can choose left or up and then we're
just going to advance it a little bit
doo doo doo and now it's used up almost
every node it has no more unvisited
neighbors around it so it's going to
have to start backtracking and it has to
take the same path back that it took to
get here so you can see as I move it's
gonna go backwards and at each point
it's gonna look at all of its neighbors
and look to see if any of them haven't
been visited and here we have one that
hasn't been visited so it'll go and
again there's nothing around it that it
can visit because they're all visited so
it'll backtrack one more and it'll see
that there's one more potential edge and
it'll follow that in
and at this point every node has been
visited so there's nothing left to do
now I can advance the simulation but it
won't actually do anything at this point
it'll just keep going backwards until
until it reaches the starting node so
let's just do that
and here we have a basic maze that it's
created you can see that the blue lines
are the edges there are in actuality
they're the pathways that you're allowed
to take rather than the walls that
indicate where you're not allowed to
take when I said before through the
walls were just a visualization they
really are what you're doing is you're
generating a graph you're not generating
walls
you're not having and removing walls
you're adding and removing edges between
nodes so I'm going to draw the walls
again and you can see that all we do is
we just go and draw lines between each
node and the lines can be drawn anywhere
because they're they don't actually
exist what exists are the nodes and the
edges between them that's what's being
manipulated here
that's it for mais generation thanks for
watching and as I said before the source
code is available online on the github
address in the description below so take
a look and so if you happen to make
anything cool out of it let me know and
finally here is the mais generation
algorithm on a much much bigger canvas
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]